[Music]
at least 10 percent of the people who've
had covet in the u.s about 2 million of
our fellow americans are considered
so-called long-haulers meaning they
still have symptoms of the virus long
after getting the virus itself
well researchers are now moving to start
a clinical trial
for experimental drugs that could help
these people but so far
none have been approved and there are
not any treatments our doctor tara
narula takes us now inside some of the
rehab clinics
or long haulers that are popping up all
across the country and she's going to
show us
how critical their situation really is
when we first met kevin raffel back in
april we love you
he had just woken up from a medically
induced coma because of covid
complications
today he's back home but hasn't fully
recovered there's a lot of memory loss
being out of breath a lot of fatigue a
lot of joint pain
things like that you wonder if you're
going to get everything back but
we don't know yet he falls in the
estimated 10 percent of covid patients
who are long-haulers
survivors who months after being
infected with the virus
are still experiencing debilitating and
often crippling symptoms
there are days when you try to get up
your body just
won't cooperate your limbs won't move
your brain is too dizzy for you to even
sit up
let alone stand up 25 year old michelle
sogi went from a fit and healthy athlete
to living with chronic muscle pain and
fatigue
shortness of breath and brain fog i
actually could no longer live by myself
anymore the symptoms were so
debilitating i couldn't
get up i couldn't shower she's now a
patient at uc davis's post covid 19
clinic
one of several new specialty care
clinics emerging across the country
specifically dedicated to treating
long-hauler patients
what happens at the post covid clinic
that you attend
yeah so initially you get seen by
whoever is the
um most appropriate person to see you
for your prominent issues so for me
that was breathing because coconut is so
unknown it's affecting people in so many
different ways
it is a multi-step multi-disciplinary
process
dr margot gage an epidemiologist
professor and mom of two
has a team of specialists working with
her on her various issues
i have skin rashes i have vision
issues i have ringing in my ears i'm on
an inhaler
and have a sort of asthma even though
i'm not
an asthmatic person she also describes
headaches
stronger than migraines and says on bad
days is bedridden
what are the doctors saying to you now
about your condition that
they are readily admitting that i have
post-covered
symptoms we have our own mode of
treatment and plan that we carry out so
it's very a one-to-one
type of treatment modality what i'm
undergoing
dr virginia witt works at an outpatient
post-covet care facility in new jersey
and says the need for these clinics is
dire we have patients who have
obviously lung damage scarring they're
short of breath
they have no exercise tolerance some of
them even need lung transplants for the
long haul
some patients are on dialysis we have
people with heart problems
no matter how good how better i get
i will never be the same person that i
was
narcisso rodriguez is one of dr witt's
patients
being treated for damage to his lungs
which has impacted his ability to work
before i used to work you know 14 16
hours a day
and it didn't bother me but now i can
one of the biggest issues seen at these
clinics is chronic fatigue
and brain fog alexandra hackett says her
life radically changed
seemingly overnight from breathlessness
to cognitive issues
i started to recognize that i've been
taking an immense amount of
concentration
to get through my day it's an itch you
can't scratch
mentally once a week she sees a
neurotherapist
at mcgee rehabilitation in philadelphia
you went from somebody who was
totally healthy to someone who now has a
cardiologist a pulmonologist
is doing neuro rehab your whole life has
changed
that's why i want to share my story
because i know that there are people out
there
long haulers who are suffering with
symptoms who are
far more debilitating keep going you
don't want
to have your future reduced to nothing
because of an illness a lot of people do
survive
a lot of people do but there are also a
host of people
who survive but are no longer the same
wow dr narula joins us now dr narula it
was great to hear those case studies but
i'm interested what are the big themes
you've heard as you interview these
so-called long haulers
well one of the big things tony is the
frustration of not being believed is
presenting to your doctor with all these
complaints and being told it's in your
head go see a psychiatrist
another centers around the anxiety of
just not knowing are these symptoms
going to get better when are they going
to get better how long is this going to
go on
and then the third big theme really
centered around suddenly becoming going
from somebody who was a caregiver to
somebody who had to be cared for
and what burden that may be placing on
their family members
but many of them spoke about the support
they're getting from these online social
media type groups and so that's been
really great for them
and dr narula i would be remiss if i let
you go without pointing out that you are
now among the
vaccinated americans at least one dose
last week you got it we have a picture
of it there
how are you feeling i feel good i had
some arm pain a little fever and chills
that night but
it was really i was so surprised at how
emotional i got i started
really tearing up at it you know it just
um all the months of being a doctor and
caring for patients myself and being
worried that i was gonna bring it home
to my family
hearing the stories of my friends and
colleagues and then being a journalist
and covering this
it was just a very emotional moment one
where
i felt a release of fear hope and just
tremendous gratitude for science no it's
emotional for us too i mean i was
hopeful when the authorizations came
through but then
frustrated as we see the slow pace of
rollout glad you got it
i'm very excited to see more and more
americans get it as well dr gorilla
thank you very much